[Music]
I have had enough of you then go before
I put you down fight
[Music]
today you have proven worthy of joining
us there are other Champions I must
gather
what do you want
it's my family blade cento's mine and I
won't give it up without a fight
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
okay let's go back to one here
who are you again Lord Liu Kang
protector of Earth rail
god of fire
[Music]
you have skills Raiden but you're
inexperienced whatever experience I lack
I make up for in heart
foreign
if your disease becomes known you will
be banished I only want what's best for
you or do you secretly covet my throne
foreign
[Music]
finish you finish here
foreign